hallo und herzlich willkommen zur schon
eins nach der sommerpause
und diesmal muss ich zugeben ist es
wirklich der wahnsinn was alles passiert
ist während unserer ferien
man kriegt das gar nicht mehr zusammen
was haben wir da alles markus söder hat
zum beispiel im juli seine vermieterin
im kanzleramt in seinen privaten
wohnzimmer in bayern entspannt eine
schöne geste oder hier auch eine ganz
tolle sommer meldung robert habeck ist
ins lasagne geschäft eingestiegen
glückwunsch dann gab es tierisch ärger
für diesen cdu schülerpraktikanten ich
glaube wegen eines ferienjobs was sagt
man dazu
wenn ich sein vater wäre hätte ich ihn
an einen wanderzirkus verschieden ja ja
ich auch hier mein heimat kreis
gütersloh hat es erstmals in die
weltpresse geschafft mann war ich stolz
du an jedoch nicht so und dann wissen
sie hat in berlin ja noch ein rechter
mordversuch den reichstag zu stürmen
wurde aber von einer hundertschaft
bestehend aus diesen polizisten
zurückgedrängt
ja gott sei dank ja war doch ein ganz
netter sommer oder ich fand schon sind
wir jetzt eigentlich wieder ein
kaiserreich nach diesem sturm wo in
wirklichkeit nur eine handvoll idioten
self es auf einer treppe gemacht hat
dann abgesehen davon diese leute die
wollen doch gar keinen kaiser die wollen
einen ganz anderen
unterdrückt von der merkel diktatur
erhoffen sie sich hilfe vom lupenreinen
demokraten putin
dann hofft mal schön wladimir putin
der feuchte traum der deutschen die es
gerne etwas härter mögen also autoritäre
aktuell müssen wir sagen ist das deutsch
russische verhältnis allerdings ja
angespannt nachdem neuwied schock
anschlag auf den oppositionellen navalny
ich sag jetzt einfach mal ganz frech
anschlag
wendel marco materazzi die ich bin denn
außer einer offiziellen analyse des
speziallabors der bundeswehr gibt es ja
keinen einzigen beweis
naughty dog also russische medien und
ärzte kommen dazu ganz anderen schlüssen
es war ein zuckerschock
es könnte aber auch eine mischung aus
alkohol und tabletten gewesen sein oder
steroide oder eine diät vielleicht hat
einer mal nicht gefrühstückt ja klar
ja klar oder er hat das falsche
gefrühstückt kann ja auch sein und
vielleicht hat er zu viele blogs taxis
gefuttert die töten den tiger in dir
oder eben doch die sache mit der diät ja
das ist in russland gerade voll der
trend die neue bodykit christa mit
absolute geheimtipp novacek diät nur
einmal trinken nimmst du wochen lang ab
ganz einfach kannst du sogar machen am
flughafen interessiert twitterst du
putin muss weg machen wir den rest wir
wissen wo du wohnst und nächste woche in
britz gar leckere herbst küche schnelle
rezepte mit polonium
jetzt am kiosk ii ich sage das seit
jahren diäten sind brandgefährlich
frauen brandgefährlich sogar angela
merkel die putin jahre lang alles hat
durchgehen lassen wieso eine montessori
kindergärtnerin auf baldrian verschärft
jetzt den ton aber wie sie fordert von
moskau aufklärung
kleiner haken nach so einer anlage
müssten theoretisch auch taten folgen
und taten sind leider nicht so unser
ding hier heiko maas erzählt ein super
witz umso dringlicher ist es nun dass
auch in russland die verantwortlichen
ermittelt und zur rechenschaft
drogen werden zur rechenschaft ziehen
russland der heiko kann morgen hier als
autor anfangen die affären allein ein
klarer fall für sherlock olli so was
wissen wir meine damen und herren ich
fasse kurz zusammen ein intimfeind von
putin ist in russland mit einem vom
russischen geheimdienst entwickelten
chemischen kampfstoff vergiftet worden
während ihnen der russische geheimdienst
24 stunden am tag überwacht hat das
erregt zumindest meine aufmerksamkeit
vielen dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit da
nicht führen natürlich wissen wir nicht
wer navalny vergiftet hat oder ob das
jemand befohlen hat tatsache ist aber
dutzende dutzende russische
oppositionelle und journalisten sind
bereits umgebracht worden und moskau hat
nie irgendwas zur aufklärung beigetragen
das system putin ist menschenverachtend
mit jedem ort soll die opposition da
natürlich weiter eingeschüchtert werden
welche spur verfolgt denn das russische
staatsfernsehen
wo wir haben nach wanne gift nach
deutschland geschickt wir zeigen diese
weise gerne seltsamerweise wurde gift
erst in deutschland entdeckt sollte
deutschland doch erklären wie gift in
den körper eines mannes kommt der gast
der kanzlerin ist
ach so das ändert alles bei unserer
kanzlerin wurde navalny vergiftet womit
mein lieblingsessen ist
spaghetti bolognese keine weiteren
fragen bei cluedo würde man sagen es war
die kanzlerin im kanzleramt mit
spaghetti bolognese
case klos ja keine angst liebe putin
fans deutschland und die eu werden am
ende sowieso wieder zur tagesordnung
übergehen wie immer die eu schafft es ja
noch nicht mal sich auf sanktionen gegen
das regime lukaschenko in belarus zu
einigen oder auf eine menschenwürdige
flüchtlingspolitik simoni und putin
testet immer weiter seine grenzen aus
deswegen haben wir jetzt die große
debatte soll man die fast fertige
gaspipeline nord stream 2 zu ende
verbuddeln oder nicht den vertrag haben
wir übrigens 2015 mit den russen gemacht
direkt nachdem die unseren bundestag
gehackt haben und ganz kurz vor den
ersten russischen bomben auf syrien
wir sind echt phoenix hier das war der
symbolische pipeline staat damals als
frau merkel noch das glücksrad moderiert
hat ich hoffe ein a und möchte lösen
navi lag also röhre fertig bauen oder
nicht
darüber wird jetzt gestritten quer durch
alle parteien klar aussteigen wäre wohl
ein tierisch teurer vertragsbruch dann
käme halt mehr gas aus anderen
russischen röhren europa ist insgesamt
schon zu abhängig von russischem gas
aber das ändern wir jetzt nicht auf die
schnelle dank der verbockten
energiewende klar wenn es nur um werte
ginge dann dürfte man mit china und
saudi arabien gar nicht mehr reden aber
es ist schon ein doofes gefühl oder
putin immer reicher zu machen mit
unserem geld während der mann wirklich
alles gibt die westlichen demokratien
kaputt zu kriegen
da ist ja siehe praxis us wahl und vor
allem in der energiepolitik gibt's jetzt
aktuell wirklich nur noch gruseliger
alternativen so liebe angela soll sein
gas dealer sein
wladimir der skrupellose chemin du dich
so gern mit seinen riesen köthen in
panik versetzt oder doch donald der
ulkige psychopath der dich zwingen will
sein völlig überteuertes flüssiggas zu
kaufen
du findest beide zum kotzen kein problem
dann kaufte ein gas beim türken der mit
dir im herzblatt hubschrauber über euer
gemeinsames flüchtlingslager
maria fliegt so liebe angela jetzt musst
du dich entscheiden in deiner haut
möchte ich nicht stecken
ich auch nicht ja liebe putin troll
armee der drohnenkrieg der amerikaner
ist auch eine völkerrechtswidrige
verbrechen es macht aber das system
putin nicht weniger eklig solche motto
bord typen kommen gerade vor allem von
politikern der linkspartei wirklich gysi
und co wiederholen fast wörtlich die
neuwahlen die nebelkerzen der russischen
propaganda
ich frage mich warum sind wahrscheinlich
auch nur alte reflexe als wären die
linken in so einer zeitschleife gefangen
ich sag mal normal ist das nicht
[Musik]
guten abend liebe werktätige mein name
ist mandy austen heute zuständig für
sport körperertüchtigung und doping der
welt freundschaft verschiedene parteien
des bürgerlichen lagers und vertreter
des verfahren kapitalistischen systems
beschuldigen aktuell die linkspartei in
der causa navalny immer noch in
denkmustern des warschauer paktes zu
fahren
dies weiß das zk der linkspartei
entschieden zurück dazu ein kommentar
von gregor gysi
ich bitte sie mit mir das glas zu
erheben und zu trinken
entschuldigung da hat der stoff
fehlerteufel eingeschlichen
diesen beitrag senden wir erst morgen
was wir nicht wissen wladimir putin
unterstützt mit seinen gas- erlösen in
not geratene deutsche senioren wie
diesen völlig verwahrlosten rentner
alles hannover und niemand weiß was mit
alexei navalny passiert ist natürlich
könnte es gewesen sein
das ist die einzige chance sei aber
selbst wenn es das nervengift gibt die
linkspartei zu bedenken dass das aus den
90er jahren eine probe in die hände des
bundesnachrichtendienst gelangt ist und
damit auch an westlicher geheimdienste
was sind gründe beweist dass die usa
wollen die mithilfe des westdeutschen
bnd umbringen wollte denn nur sie hatten
in motiv wem nützt es
die berner jetzt soll der sänger von
youtube play new york am rande tweet vom
ehemaligen linken vorsitzenden klaus
ernst
wem nützt die vergiftung der wein ist
etwa die bahn aber nicht so gefährlich
nach 76 kaputt die 2018 also
entschuldigung aber was ist das denn für
ein zynischer quatsch putin hat ja nur
76 prozent geholt weil es in russland
keine richtige opposition gibt an dass
er sich dabei wollen sie die
offizielle parteilinie etwa freie
stellen sind sie dann nicht mensch
gottes willen nein
mich ärgert nur diese nibelungentreue
der linken zu putin meine die linken
müssten fans von navalny sein
der deckt die ganze kriminelle
bereicherung von putin und seine
griechen auf besondere aufmerksamkeit
schenkt navalny einer mit detlef villa
mit sehr großzügige menden teich samt
eigenem häuschen für die enten
ich freue mich ja für die enden aber
diese hütte in frankreich gehört
enteignet sowie das vermögen von putins
andere verbrecher freundin ganz europa
auch war die linke nicht immer flüssen
gilt das nur für bono via zwingen sie
mich nicht ihren führungsoffizieren zdf
anzurufen putin unterstützt rechte
parteien in ganz europa rechte allein
deswegen müsste die linke doch als
antifaschistische partei
ja liebe zuschauer
der kollege welge lässt sich
entschuldigen er hat sich wohl bei der
zubereitung einer tasse tee beide beine
gebrochen
wir wünschen an dieser stelle gute
besserung ist am schluss wie immer das
wetter auch mit unserem bett auf angela
lueger würde ich die partie hier sind ja
das klingt doch sehr vielversprechend
[Musik]
ja it-service beweise sprechen mit
jürgen wie kann ich ihnen weiterhelfen
haben sie mal versucht das gerät aus und
wieder einzuschalten hat nichts gebracht
verstehe
probieren sie doch mal den kanal der
heute show auf youtube zu abonnieren
genau und im zweifel wo ich auch mal den
gefällt mir -button klicken
genau ja ich bleibe in der leitung